wandering with the $25,000 initial grant
when did you realize you needed more and
then how did you end up getting more
funding what was your process well we we
knew we needed more and we got to know
two grandsons of the first unit members
Harry Davidson in Manhattan and Mike
Davis in Atlanta they're cousins and
share a grandfather Truby Davison and we
asked them to be on our fundraising
committee and for I think three and a
half years every Thursday morning at 6
a.m. West Coast time we would talk to
them about you know people they knew
foundations they might be aware of to
raise money and we wrote a lot of
letters and Ron and I we'd go to these
coasts to interview people and do
production and film planes or whatever
we do and then we'd go to New York and
we'd show what we had at the Dolby
screening room there and try to get
people to write checks for us and you
know we'd get $100 here $100 there and
it just it just really wasn't doing it
but Ron started writing a quarterly
newsletter and we started collecting
email addresses and sending this out and
letting them know it was going and
gradually it got out to more and more
foundations we we learned that there was
a level of of money and foundations that
you don't really hear about but but that
wealthy families you know have to give
away X amount of money every year for
for tax purposes and so there were
people that had some relation to the
story whether it was through Yale
whether it was through the Navy or
whether they just wanted to hear a
patriotic see a patriotic story being
told and then and we kept trying for a
corporate sponsor we we worked on JP
Morgan for for over two years because
originally Truby Davis and young guy who
founded the unit his father was JP
Morgan's business partner and JP Morgan
had given the four CEO unit $100,000 to
get started and buy airplanes and so we
knew some people working at Morgan and
we went to them and said we'd like the
same amount of money adjusted for
inflation
we were asking for $200,000 but all that
time we were working out every week in
the news there just be horrible reports
about their corporate behavior and Jamie
Dimon and they've done this and they've
done that and and but you know what we
still wanted the money we still kept
trying to get it and the end it fell
through and and I think sort of out of
embarrassment and kindness they gave us
$25,000 which which helped but in the
end our corporate sponsor was FedEx and
we had been wanting to go to them for a
long time because Fred Smith the founder
went to Yale he started the Yale Aero
Club and I think he was a marine but he
flew he flew with the Navy I think in
Vietnam or at least during Vietnam and
so we were all but sure he'd be aware of
the story and indeed the story was
something that really meant something to
him he was also a member of skull and
bones the way probably five of these
first Yale unit guys were as well and so
in the end gap they came through with
the last hundred and fifty thousand
dollars that we needed to finish the
film yeah I mean in terms of the other
little bit on fundraising that I'll
mention is that our fundraising was
always driven by necessity so it wasn't
like we were just trying to raise money
randomly for you know to say oh we would
like to raise you know twenty two
hundred fifty thousand dollars or
something like that never was like that
it was always based on necessity so we
as we were developing the script and we
started editing we'd realize there was a
big chunk that we needed to go somewhere
to film or a group of people that we
needed to interview and just and then we
budget for those particular parts of the
film so we yes we had an overall budget
for the film but as we went along over
those seven years we kind of did mini
budgets where we said oh we need to do
that particular shoot how much does that
particular shoot gonna cost okay it's
going to cost and we break it all down
travel whatever else was involved and
and then we been our fundraising efforts
would drive toward fulfilling that
particular chunk so in the newsletter we
would say we need twenty five thousand
dollars to film a sopwith camel or we
need twenty thousand dollars for our
composer right those were two things
that we really put out there saying this
is the next big thing we need and you
know we would be out of money you know
at each of each of these stages yeah and
this was a quarterly newsletter you said
that you uh it was intended to be a
quarterly newsletter and most of the
time it was quarterly but a couple times
it was off schedule but generally it was
a quarterly yes so you it does I find
that fascinating so you would weave in
like your own stories or different
things and then you also had information
on what was next for the final yeah as a
matter of fact the first thing that we
did before we even started fundraising
seriously was that we actually put our
website together first which was kind of
a little weird way of doing it you know
and what we did as part of our website
is we put up the imagery that we already
had and we started to create kind of a
historical online museum as it were and
and the the website that we first put up
is actually still up there today
but that gave us kind of somewhere where
our potential contributors followers
could go and see you know what we were
about and what we were trying to do over
time and then as people got on the on
the email list that you know that there
was the added reach out reach with the
newsletter actually the very first thing
we did after we put together the
nonprofit organization and got our board
together which were friends of ours is
Ron and I put together a PowerPoint
presentation yeah what the story was and
they all fell asleep was this that like
some type of a mixers no is it my house
here's the story and I applied them with
wine and you know fell asleep
you